did you ever wonder what would happen if
Doma was sent to the swordsmith Village
or what about if Tundra's Dad decided to
join the Demon Slayer core and best of
all what would happen if the strongest
Demon Slayer ever yorichi was born in
the current ERA well after spending
countless hours rereading the Demon
Slayer manga I figured out exactly what
would happen so you all know how Doma
wanted to join huntengu and gyoko in the
raid on the swordsmith village but since
nakame refused to teleport him he ended
up not going however what if he actually
managed to persuade muzan to let him go
would the demon Slayers have any chance
of stopping him well there are three
possible ways the story could go from
here and the first one is that Doma gets
sent along with Han Tengu and gyoko this
means that there will now be three upper
moons in the village at the same time in
the original story The Slayers have
barely managed to defeat two of them and
with Doma there there is absolutely no
way any of them would survive okay that
was pretty straightforward but what if
Domo was sent with only one other upper
move with the outcome be any different
in this scenario we can assume that
gyoko would engage muichiro same as in
the original leaving Doma to face Tundra
nezuko and genya you are probably
thinking how these three would be killed
instantly in this battle but that's
really not the case you see during his
battle against shinobus we've seen that
Doma loves to play with his opponents
slowly harming them and treating them as
prey because of this it's really
unlikely he would go all out and just
kill them on the spot but why is this
even important well if Slayers managed
to stall him for long enough they'll be
in a much better situation and that's
because mitsuri the love is Shira will
join the battle instead of being mad
that another strong Demon Slayer came to
fight him Doma would be thrilled to see
a female pillar and couldn't wait to
devour her so with mitsuri's arrival the
Slayers surely have at least some chance
of winning right well no they'll
actually lose pretty quickly and there's
a simple explanation for that do you
remember how hard it was for them to
defeat hontango in the original story
even with tanjaro's red weapon and
Missouri's Demon Slayer Mark they barely
managed to survive although we've never
seen doma's full strength in the manga
it's clear that he is exponentially
stronger than hontengu and therefore
would easily kill all the Slayers and
destroy enjoy the entire Village okay
these two scenarios ended really badly
for the demon Slayers but what if
instead of going with the other upper
moons Doma went to the Village alone
would the Slayers be able to finally
defeat this hit the Subscribe button to
wish them good luck since gyoko is not
present in this version it means that
muichiro would be able to help this time
and with mitsuri's arrival there will
now be two hashiras along with tanjaro's
group battling the demon together Dumbo
would finally have to get serious at
this point and the intense battle would
start initially doma's power and speed
would surprise the Slayers and he'd
managed to seriously injure them using
his cryokinesis blood demon art but just
as he is about to kill them both
morichiro and mitsuri awaken their Demon
Slayer marks and start countering his
attacks surprising the upper moon from
here Tantra would also activate his Mark
and with nezuko's help he'll turn his
weapon bright red Doma would start to
get pressured by the demon Slayers even
sustaining some injuries but this
quickly changes as he activates his most
powerful technique rhyme water lily
buddhisattva the enormous ice statue
suddenly appears and starts attacking
all the demon Slayers Gravely wounding
them although it seems that Doma has won
now and that all the Slayers are going
to die the demon actually made one big
mistake that will allow everyone to
survive five can you guess what it is if
you said that Doma has played with his
opponents for too long at the beginning
and the Sun is now starting to rise you
are right no matter how overpowered Doma
is he can't survive in the sunlight so
he would have to retreat leaving
everyone else exhausted on the ground
man I'm glad muzan didn't let Doma go to
the Village the demon Slayers would
stand no chance before we move on let me
tell you guys about the sponsor of
today's video War Thunder War Thunder is
a free-to-play game available for PC and
consoles and it has the most
comprehensive vehicle combat I've ever
seen you can choose between 2 000
different tanks planes or ships and a
battle other players in PvP battles
every single one of these vehicles is
really well made and most of them even
have the unique anime themed skins this
is personally the thing I like the most
as I can switch this boring looking
plane to a GUI themed one how cool is
that same as Demon Slayer War Thunder
looks beautiful I mean just look at this
level of detail it's mind-blowing the
game also lets you choose your play
playing style whether you prefer a fast
action-packed match or more down to
earth tactical gameplay like I do you
are guaranteed to have fun click my link
in the description to download War
Thunder now and you'll get all of these
amazing bonuses plus a 3D anime body
pillow to put on your tank a true anime
fan would definitely not miss out on
that offer before we explain what would
happen if yorichi was born in the
current ERA let's first explain what
would happen if tantaro's Dad decided to
become a Demon Slayer although we didn't
see much of Tantra throughout the series
it's obvious that the guy had incredible
potential not only did he know kagura
dance but he also had Demon Slayer Mark
and even selfless State ability
something that tantro only unlocked
during The Last Arc so what if a guy
like this wasn't sick and decided to
join the Demon Slayer core and fight
Demons What would change in this version
of the story and would he be powerful
enough to take down muzon first of all
if tanjaro decided to become a Slayer he
would probably do it during his 20s
since that's when his physical strength
is at its peak this means that tantro
and nezuko still be really young when he
left and couldn't come with him it's not
clear how much knowledge tanjaro had
about Demon Slayer core but it's certain
that he at least knew of their existence
so he would probably go to the final
selection in order to become a member
using hinokami kakura he would easily
kill every single demon on the mountain
surprising everyone kagaya would soon
get a word about a strong Demon Slayer
using Sun breathing and invite him to
Butterfly Mansion since this scenario
takes place around five years before the
original story it means that the hashira
lineup would be completely different
this time around with most of the
original hashiras not being demon
Slayers yet this is really interesting
as it means we may get to see some of
the former hashiras like shinjiro canal
and maybe even urokodaki with only a few
months of training in the core Tundra
would become the strongest Warrior of
his generation and would join the
pillars as Sun hashira another important
thing to remember here is that tantro is
naturally born with the Demon Slayer
Mark same as yorichi and tanjaro and
therefore he would most likely awaken
all the legendary Demon Slayer abilities
including bright red weapon and
transparent World due to his kind nature
Tantra would offer to teach Slayers
these new abilities making the core many
times stronger than in the original
story with his help the core would also
be powerful enough to battle against
upper moons something they could only
dream of before not long after the word
of the mysterious sun-breathing user
would reach muzon and he'd be absolutely
terrified I mean just look at Tantra and
you're reaching next to each other same
earrings the same breathing style the
same hair they look pretty much
identical same as in the manga muzon
wouldn't dare to go after Tundra himself
and would instead keep sending his
subordinates to eliminate him but let's
be real here if Tantra and the original
hashiras managed to defeat most of the
upper moons tanzaro and these new
overpowered pillars would definitely be
able to deal with anything muzon throws
at them although everything seems to be
going pretty well there is one big
problem with this development do you
remember how the corps found muzon in
the original story that's right they
didn't muzon actually found them in
order to eat nezuko and gain immunity to
sunlight however since neziko isn't a
demon this time around smoozan doesn't
have a single reason to reveal himself
you may think Tantra and the other
pillars can just go out and look for him
but you're forgetting something the
infinity castle that's right with
nakamus help muzon can just stay there
for as long as he wants and nobody will
ever find him this ultimately means that
tantro and all other hashiras will
eventually grow old or die in battle
without ever even seeing the Demon King
since muzon remained hidden for years
this also means he wouldn't be able to
attack the Commodore family leading to
nezuko and tandro never becoming Corps
members eventually after years have
passed with both tantro and tandro out
of the picture The Demon King starts to
grow in power once again and although
the new pillars would definitely be
really strong there's just no way they
could defeat muzon without the help of a
sun-breathing user alright that scenario
went way worse than I thought but did
you ever wonder what would happen if the
Demon Slayer God yorishi tsubikuni was
born in Tundra's ERA with the two
sunbreathers fight alongside each other
and would yurichi finally managed to
defeat muzon in this timeline well I'll
have to break your hopes in the very
beginning tandro and yorishi will
unfortunately not fight together since
yorichi now lives in the current
timeline it means that he never showed
kagura dance to tanzaro's ancestors
which would lead to tonsro being just a
normal boy with no powers whatsoever he
wouldn't even have the Demon Slayer Mark
okay that's unfortunate but let's return
to yorichi what would he do in this
timeline in the original story Twins
were considered bad luck and therefore
yurichi and his brother were treated
very differently ultimately leading to
michikatsu being envious and jealous of
yorishi however in the current timeline
nobody believes in that stuff anymore
meaning that both twins would be raised
the same way and trained together to
become Swordsmen another major change in
this scenario is that the Demon Slayer
core would be much weaker than in the
original as yorichi never taught them
how to use breathing Styles this
basically means that the core would
consist of order ordinary Samurai
Warriors and they would struggle to
defeat even the low ranking demons
because of this muzon and his army of
demons would freely roam during the
night knowing that there is nobody
strong enough to stand in their way
yorichi and michikatsu would eventually
grow up and become really strong but
most importantly due to their normal
upbringing there will be no hatred
between them from here it's most likely
that some of the demon Slayers would try
to recruit the twins because of their
phenomenal swordsmanship and considering
yorichi's willingness to help others he
would accept from here the Golden Age of
demon Slayers would start and yorichi
would develop the first ever breathing
style Sun breathing same as in the
original yorichi would teach others how
to use this mysterious power eventually
creating six main breathing Styles it
goes without saying that he would easily
become the son hashira and everyone in
the core would look up to him seeing him
as their leader the demon Slayers would
now be stronger than ever and for the
first time in many years they'll be able
to fight back against demons now in the
previous scenario we talked about how
muzon goes into hiding whenever he feels
threatened however this time that won't
actually happen you see in this timeline
muzan never lost a duel with yorichi
meaning he still believes he is the
strongest being in the world and
therefore there is no reason to hide in
the original manga we can see that muzan
knew about breath users but he still
didn't care and said he wasn't
interested in them so we can assume he
would act the same this time
a few years after urichi joined the core
he and his brother would Patrol a nearby
Village during the night when out of
nowhere they sense a terrifying presence
appear right in front of them they had
never sensed an aura as powerful as this
one before and when they look up they
see the Demon King muzon standing before
them as in the original muzon wouldn't
waste any time and immediately attack
the Slayers with his transformed arm
although yorishi would Dodge his brother
would get hit and thrown to the ground
yorichi would quickly realize who he was
up against and in a split second he'd
perfect his breathing style and sliced
all of muzon's weak points
simultaneously seriously injured and in
utter disbelief muzon would panic and
split his body into 1800 different
pieces in order to escape in the blink
of an eye the Richie would manage to cut
1500 pieces and just as it seemed that
muzon would manage to escape mijikatsu
would jump forward with his brother and
using his Moon breathing barely managed
to slice the remaining 300 pieces with
this the Demon Lord who terrorized Japan
for over a millennia would finally be
defeated Forever by the combined Power
of Two Brothers others don't forget to
click the link in the description to
download War Thunder now and get all of
these amazing bonuses on screen plus
that 3D anime body pillow which you
definitely don't want to pass on and who
knows maybe we'll see each other in the
game click on this video where we
covered what would happen if all demon
moons attacked muzon together